i wrote it in a time when we were a  little bit worried about the future of  cinema so the first thing i knew is i i  wanted to create a spectacle i wanted to  create something that the audience would  have to come see  and so you know i set my my sights on  you know the great american ufo story  here and the movie itself uh deals with  spectacle and and the good and bad that  come from this idea of attention  it's a horror epic but it has some  points in it that are meant to elicit a  very audible reaction in the theater um  so hopefully when we go see it we're  going to hear a lot of nope  all right  walking back in  that's what i'm looking for